so I I had I had three things I thought
I would just bring up and they're short
and I promise so so I had
same room with intellectual heroes is
great I feel like I'm 12 because I first
read many many people here when I was 12
that's right you're always the youngest
person in the room were the oldest so
that's true so the thing I learned a
huge amount about was reductionism
explanation inner theoretic
relationships the first day was just
huge for me I understood Shawn much
better this notion of entailment these
are some really provocative concepts
that I'm going to take back and wrestle
with and thank you for for indulging me
when I tried to put something up on the
board as I'm really grateful
one thing I was surprised we didn't get
into as much was functionalism so you
know evolution is a huge pillar of
modern science and I think functionalism
is too I should I've been told I should
explain better so I was talking to david
poeppel
last night about his work and his work
is about the computational states of the
brain at least as I interpret it the way
that we talk about the way David talks
about it seems to be in some ways the
domain of computer science particular
theoretical computer science and which
is how I how I think about social
systems and yet there seem to be a huge
number of problems that emerge there
that are both conceptually interesting
and also perhaps provocative for notions
of responsibility moral responsibility
and so let me just bring up one right so
we like to attach moral value to the
conscious part of ourselves if I'm
sleepwalking and I kill somebody maybe I
shouldn't be held responsible for it
even if the best rational engagements of
my brain are making me do it and I
there's something we slid past a little
bit here which was what if the conscious
part of our brain is not the most
rational part should that part to that
part we don't feel be given value
related to that are we think better in
groups so should conversations be these
citizens should they have rights should
if Dan and Rebecca are having a great
conversation and their mental states are
interacting with each other in producing
a larger scale computation
first of all does it feel anything
second of all should we you know confine
them so that this conversation doesn't
stop or maybe conversations like to die
there like banthas or the meal that at
the end of the universe that the
restaurant of the interview is the one
who wants to be eaten so and I think the
third thing I hope I'm not have how much
time do I have dad though two minutes
two minutes great so I'll be very
quickly so biology and neuroscience to
me seem like very mature subjects
actually and it's one of the reasons
perhaps they don't work in them because
it seems like many of the research
programs are very clear and the many of
the things you want to do it's like
let's get some dishes and do the right
things and I've been disabused of that
by the exchanges in this corner of the
room here but one thing I would love to
see more discussion of is the some of
the questions that come up in economics
or social sciences and so Dom brought
some of these up so I've always had this
feeling that game theory was secretly
about rationality okay good okay so
people say the rational thing to do is
defect and that's why Nash equilibrium
were these kind of thing I'm like what's
going on there and I would love to see a
little more excavation as to what
economics and the social sciences say
about thinking what it means to think
what the nature of rationality is I
think you brought this up a little bit
and I and I missed it I have you know
just parenthetically it would be lovely
to excavate that more if we came back
it's just to go to the sciences that are
really fuzzy and dirty and we're sort of
the questions maybe or as simple or and
more obvious to play with so anyway I'm
of course very grateful and you've been
very kind to the to answer my questions
I'm really grateful thank you
[Music]
you